have you ever did you ever ahead of this
fight knowingly take a a performance
enhancing substance I never did no I
never took anything which was illegal
um obviously I have a big team around me
to make sure that I'm taking the right
supplements and the right things so when
it first came that I was positive
I mean it was more of a shock to it me
and the team and everybody
um I was tested
throughout the whole training camp
um this result of me being positive came
out
literally weeks after the fight
you know which normally you think it'll
be only a week because it was weeks
after the fight it was hard for me to
then uh think what what was the what
what did I do wrong or there was there
something I took or something I was
taking any of the vitamins so I can then
pick up on what I've been taking and I
can then work out how I how that
substance is in my body
so you know it was a it was a big shock
to me and that's why I wanted to come
out and as soon as it was announced in
the newspapers I want to come out and
give my
um I don't want to hide away so just to
be clear about the chronology this this
positive test was from the night of the
fight itself yeah so this positive test
was
um the night of the fight against Kell
Brook uh throughout the whole training
camp I was tested around about eight
times and I was I couldn't wait before I
think including a week before yeah and I
was I was negative and it was just
probably days before when I must have
been positive even though in in that
test went into a fight it played the
worst performance I've ever had as a
fighter
um didn't feel like myself
um and then realized that maybe it's
time to call it a day from the sport
boxing I retired after that you've been
a remarkable figure in British sports
not just British boxing and I don't want
to be remembered for something like this
how much does that potentially yeah
exactly it all hurt me a lot because if
people remember me for just this uh
incident that happened I think it'll
always upset me because I know it was
never it was never done by purpose
um but like I said um we just have to um
hopefully people believe me and um
yeah maybe take more precaution now
another fact is for especially young up
and coming Fighters maybe they can learn
from me how mistakes can happen